bella tutti ragazzi ho deciso di fare a
way out che è un gioco dove bisogna
evadere di prigione e per farlo bisogna
lavorare in due perché due persone vader
anno di prigione ora sono io è una è
ciccio merlino bisogna evadere di
prigione ragazzi io con la mia mentalità
è la mia furbizia e ciccio con il suo
naso lungo inizia la serie su a way out
buona visione dobbiamo selezione
personaggio caruso bellissimo schiavi
del caruso è ben fatto sesso per te tu
leo caruso io che non vincent e moretti
vedi che siamo dei carcerati amici siamo
già dentro e noi non capivo se partiamo
da fuori o dentro
ad una prigione del 1600 a giudicare da
come sono vestiti io vedo ci ha donato
dall altro spreco fisso si vede solo
quello d'altro ovviamente mi hanno
incarcerato con la camicia dal mafioso
per certo se ti con una giacca sopra mi
hanno tenuto così come atto segue la
destra io sono presidi sfiorato
costantemente la tua visuale bellissimo
che succede io sono a sinistra sta
scendendo dall'autobus tu sei lì adesso
ti passano davanti al mille per cento
lo so sono mille che si affacciano
eccoti a spettacoli quali è che cita tra
i 16 al fratello chi si sentisse
costantemente la visuale nell'app del
compagno e ce la faccio a salve e ruth
toccate entra mi devo sfogliare bravi
fanno spogliare mentre mi sfogliano
raccontarvi un po come la vita da
carcerato che guarda io devo dire che
guarda qua sono molto libro diciamo ad
acqua lo soccorre consigli che ha
pensato ieri fuori non guardare a
sinistra a vantarsi di star ciccio che
un progetto che guardi a sinistra
adesso quando quella è acqua non è come
pensi perché sono sempre io corro nudo
per avercelo del sud ma tu hai detto
fassino ovunque siamo ci sono date
picchiano cosa succede
c'è il naso più brutto del mio non puoi
averlo quello che ha detto sono qui sono
qui a non guardarmi l'uccello è aia
stanno picchiando della gente non io
grazie a dio io milano e quasi da quello
di fiacca 6 facendosi sono soci co.co.co
meno male che ha menato quello sbagliato
andiamo da ciccio guardami guardami
completamente nudo a no aspetta uno
visto sto passando una ragazza è più
lungo di me vai avanti oh che bello ma
io sono nudo mi piace un sacco sta cosa
mandare questo no però sbagliato cosa ci
accordiamo labbro e non ti conviene
perché c'è un uccello dei fuori un'altra
ancora di sopraponte grosso sta prigione
va dicendo da alcatraz scopo di un film
e se questa è la mia cella che arrivò
sono davanti alle scale la cella eccoli
sono di soli qualche brutta e va bene
era chiaramente sono stati non c'è il
peggio rispetto a quanto pare nuovo
vicino chi è vediamo il metodo sicuro lo
so che ai video su youtube ea 4 mila
iscritti e si crede un film a posto
bravo a prenderlo a schiaffi hanno così
che nasce da vicino lo chalet un'offesa
mio compagno di cella che figata 15
possiamo tirare testate al muro durante
la notte
essi e controllare si scoraggi di center
a fare cose brutte ci sembra fatti i
cazzi tuoi
ma perché son tipo molto famoso totti e
che ero nome sopra non c'è la base è
sempre bene a tutti i ragazzi a chi
street e spunti di interesse visionare
ottima io posso cosa sto facendo di
dolci credo questa pasta fai nella vita
reale non ne faccio neanche un quarto a
me mi fa male di te ti giuro prodi su
operosi ti su bordi sul 10 10
lorenzo veniva da ridere c'è gente però
vado avanti che ci blocca la strada
provenienti da quello bianco vengo delle
persone che ci bloccano ciao ciccio
ma no no no ho notato da un giorno già
ti devo salvare il culo con chi paga
bene ha detto marco fatti lui e marco
con rilevanti se siete ha dato un thin
light quindi per me invece dunque grande
asili capisco brutti
apriti con te perché ci hai un naso
gigante che lo rende noto per quello e
arrivo arrivo stavo guardando i miei
scritti che adesso arrivino ecco chi è
qui ciò amico facciamo le views 2
youtuber vendo un aggrediti in prigione
migliaia views a posto suddiviso
liberato a 5 mai i balconi aspetta che
non sui tasti mamma mm che usa e pm5
penso che lo so tasto sinistro del mouse
e il tasto destro
le premesse comunque bene devo scontare
la fusco sempre invece non sei capace
bravo del katanga attacca attacca o
brevissimo ciccio di sinistra sinistro
destro bello vincere in francia
dell'arezzo bruce lee ryan
mamma mia che cartoni in bocca ma che
sta ammazzando
intanto ci attacca teca ciao a chiocchio
pecca ma che loro che ceffone che nasce
ciclone
oggi vediamo noi due si è parlato quelli
noi sicuro o mamma mia nicchia ma dai
contenuti del te la passo dopo passo
line
lei è che gioco di squadra di carte ca
ate lorenzo a tenore grazie tech grossa
grossa che la prenda al volo ma ronaldo
in tanti poliziotti
dalle rivolte alla tv ne abbiamo di
taranto 26 febbraio ma neanche un film è
stato carino ed è bello
becky scritto in giro di questi stage ma
per che cosa ti ho quasi mai trattato
male come una pezza pro scusa che non è
colpa per questo è o il ciclo sto
personaggio è mai fatto buon viso a
cattivo naso granma organo dei calmati
quella comunque a roma migliore di
quello che mangio io quando mi cucina
ecco che qualcuno tu sei troppo figo in
realtà un serio ragazzino però aiuti
crowther il 26 ci sia proprio quello che
ci blocca cosa ma basta tiro ma che
palle questo posto ammazzavano marco e
basta ma gang che fastidio e niente dove
ci uniamo dove e finiamolo i due c'è
sempre lista se c'è verso la riusciamo a
fare una roba normale questo la massey
giorno si dice passano a giornata della
ligue chiaro e va bene ma dobbiamo
essere bravi ciccio ok allora ci sono a
quello sì ma dobbiamo essere bravi ok ma
allora si becca del tirato una roba di
alluminio in faccia di ma adesso in
bocca in bocca
eccoci qua insieme
noi facciamo oggi occhio 8 coltello
occhio ammazzo l'ammazzo ma danno
carezze pugni e mi sa che dico ma questo
taglio anche ai poliziotti è ucciso uno
sul serio al povero il poliziotto
pinchia l'ammazzato nell'amare che lo
stanno menando forte e vincerà valentia
secondo me non si rialza più
il caio di giorno lorenzo solo da
un'altra volta di giorgio ha malmenato
dalla barba lo attendiamo dalla barba ma
si cazzo
tu sei finita watt è andata bene cioè
che l'infermiera gnocca ma sin da cosa
dopo che vuole siringa gli alti ma è un
[ __ ] di persona come fai rimorchiare
una donna a fargli vedere che sei un
uomo la prima cosa che dice addio il
bravissimo ai caccia vive perfetto se
cosa fa si fugge e sempre
dall'infermeria quando si scappa di
prigione attenzione ricorda solo questo
ecco io sto dormendo sono proprio io
questo prego premio talmente il mio si è
deciso di parlarti di mi fermo qua
eccetera mi serve una cosa quale cosa
quasi mai ben guardare è guardabile
sconfiggere gli iscritti
fuochi modo noi so quanto sera scibile o
ma che il ciclo cosa che può adesso sa
che fa e ci pensi o poi ma io di sicuro
vabbè per forza ti aiuto intanto c è
lorenzo a io posso fare aiuta l'euro
recupera l'attrezzo a ok
possiamo già fare la cosa ha natura
recupera 3 punti fini si traggono
infermiere questi delle carezze
ciao ciccio ieri qua da meno buone
carezzine ma certo che vai via che devo
chiamare infermiera perché si fa sconti
perché nasconditi ed ha chiarito il
termine
quella non è entrata prima non ti vede
più li fiorilli prima non ci sei più non
dice ieri che va bene e via via sente
niente vomitare posso avere l'acqua
quando felice andare ma qua c'è quello
come faccio io quando posso andarmene di
novara mi aspetto ora guarda disposti o
qualcosa vai vai vai non c'è più
occhio che si sta facciali che vai vai
vai vai così bravissimo provincia
palermo fermo dove è l'oggetto è lì dove
c'è il puntino poi aveva ma se è no
ok ma come faccio adesso sai che non ho
capi e distratte la sua in qualche modo
sauri siciliani questo signore vi siete
pero la cosa infatti moussa aspetta si è
rovesciato deficiente ok prendi o prendi
o bravo ciccio così ci si ammala maniera
che landi e siamo ci siamo allora il
primo passo per un primo passo per
un'evasione incredibile di prigione
esatto vivo o
perfetto no no grazie zia posto perché
non corretto vogliono ai cori che
camminata stupida cia e sei tornato lì
la tiffany c'e niente e si è infatti
fatta perché puoi ammazzarlo taglia
questo sono buttato un cacciavite
gigantesco delle macchine a un tanto poi
associato e non è esatto come fai
recuperarlo e busto vedremo lo so penso
che vedremo più quella sera sera quindi
già no non penso una prima notte sarebbe
troppo strano intanto ci ciò che pensa a
un naso troppo lungo come devo farti
come faccio di lorenzo e se dicessi tipo
mi ha fatto sia mamma no troppo
sbagliato che cosa posso di curly prima
cosa fa lui è appunto bene ora sono
costruttori così a casa sua c'è poi chi
di voi uscite sono un [ __ ]
ok ok va bene il gioco allora va bene
non usciremo mai aveva dentro è stata
questa
quindi usciremo di prigione non si sa
come non si sa perché ma usciremo
ma oggi sono stati sicuramente sarà un
casino incredibile vorremmo raccogliere
oggetti per quindi ragazzi concordiamo
che questo primo episodio di a way out
ciccio se vi piace continueremo questa
serie e parleremo di prigione
io e lui perché ciccio fa quello che c'è
e ci vede più lungo col naso ma era
tanto però vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cose
che dice e mi piace anche ai social news
tiziana se avessi stiate da ragazzi
[Musica]